ils sont étudiants bénévoles archéologue
et géologue et fouillent cette fausse
depuis plus de deux semaines
et là on fait danser dans cette fosse
qu'on espère trouver quelque chose qui
ressemble à des marques ici sur lesquels
je suis ses vastes butte de terre repéré
dès les années 90 renferme des trésors
les vestiges d'une motte castrale sorte
de fortifications servant de résidence
seigneuriale au moyen-âge on a en
général une structure circulaire
remblayer sur laquelle on va trouver une
sorte de petit château fort en bois on
va dire une fortification en général
enterré bois donc ce qu'on va essayer de
retrouver ici sont des structures en
creux évidemment le bois disparaît mais
il va rester les structures en négatif
des trous de poteaux des fausses et puis
d'ego de sol donc des niveaux qu'on a
aménagé pour marcher pour vivre
plusieurs clous et des morceaux de
céramique ont été trouvés des objets
précieux qui permettent de remonter le
temps ça c'est un fourneau de pipe en
terre blanche donc 18e et puis on a des
tessons beaucoup plus anciens qui sont
antique ou médiévaux ça nous permet de
remonter avant les premières archives
qu'on a à la fin du xiiie siècle sur le
village défauts séparés par quelques
kilomètres de distance
ce n'est pas un mais trois sites qui
sont actuellement fouillée sur le
plateau des fours ici un fort à pois
plus loin un four à chaux du 14e siècle
les blocs de la gueule du four les blocs
de là l'envié ils ont sans doute servi
plusieurs fois dans un rayon de 30 km
1500 four à chaux ont été localisés
certains font plus de 12 m de diamètre
preuve que la quantité de chaud produit
dépasse largement les besoins de
consommation locale il s'agit peut-être
d'exploitation de calcaire quasi
industrielle voire exportatrices on sort
un peu du schéma d'une autre chaîne du
jura qui va se peupler à partir du 11e
12e siècle à l'initiative des moines qui
viennent défricher la forêt petit à
petit à travers ce type d'objets
archéologiques et bien on a un portrait
qui se dessine doucement autour d'un
territoire d'une forêt ressources
où l'homme est présent d'un grand
intérêt pour les chercheurs ces
structures dont un nouvel éclairage sur
l'histoire de cette région est apte à
comprendre la façon dont le massif du
jura a été peuplée et exploiter au fil
des millénaires